[Musique]
trouvaient devant la porte d'une prison
c'est impressionnant en ce sens petit un
citoyen face à une grosse structure une
grosse institution l'état tout ce qu'il
a de plus régaliens
ce jour-là il y a dix huit ans
maintenant j'avais rendez vous avec le
directeur de la prison
j'étais pas très fier je sonnais je me
dis pourvu qu'il m'arrive pas un malheur
aujourd'hui que je rentre sain et sauf
le surveillant qui m'ouvre la porte du
lycée vous constituer prisonnier
monsieur je dis non tiens rendez vous
avec le directeur c'est prévu or avec un
sourire au coin des lèvres il m'ouvre la
porte je franchis la porte un autre qui
me crie sur moi de loin pour les draps
venez par ici si aujourd'hui la
distribution alors j'avance encore pas
très rassuré se rendent chez le
directeur au contraire lui il était
humain est ouvert et il voulait
justement pour sa population pénale qui
devenait difficile à gérer
vous voulez un référent musulmans un
aumônier musulman qui travaillerait à
côté de l'aumônier catholique protestant
depuis ce jour là j'y vais régulièrement
dans les prisons dans le grand ouest
nous sommes aujourd'hui une équipe d'une
trentaine de personnes
et j'aimerais vous parler du profil de
ces jeunes
d'abord au niveau famille école
formation professionnelle et emploi
leur profil pénale ce qui m'a choqué au
niveau 2 de leur profil familial c'est
que pratiquement tous où les trois
quarts les 9/10 proviennent de familles
monoparentales tout le temps le papa est
toujours absent pas d'autorité et quand
je leur pose des questions willy ou
tempère le dit la dernière fois j'ai vu
il ya dix ans ou un autre qui me dit je
n'ai jamais vu un jeune de 14 ans mineur
il dit mon père celui qui m'a élevé que
je croyais terme en terre en fait il
n'est que
mon beau-père et à l'âge de 10 ans il me
disait qu'il divorçait de vin moment et
qui n'a jamais été mon père voilà le
cadeau qu'il reçoit à 10 ans je me
rappelle par la suite il avait les
larmes aux yeux il m'a dit si tu vas
dans tel pays
mon papa il habite dans tel pays si tu
veux bien me le rechercher et avec
l'aide d'un réseau de médecins on a
réussi à retrouver le papa qui nous
avait un courrier pour son fils voilà un
peu le profil familial
un autre qui me dit moi mineurs aussi
saison je crois une dit moi je volais
tout simplement pour donner de l'argent
maman pour qu'elle nous achète à manger
ce sont des profils saisissant qui
traduisent un peu la souffrance de
certaines familles
au niveau scolaire pratiquement quand
ils n'écrivent un petit texte un petit
mot un rendez vous il y à une faute à
chaque mot une faute d'orthographe à
chaque mot la plupart des croches et
arrêtent d'aller à l'école à 13 14 ans
donna reed qui m'a dit ceci j'aurais
bien aimé moi comment copains avoir une
maman qui me donna un goûter quand je
rentre le soir et qui me met à table
pour m'aider à faire mes devoirs mais
malheureusement maman quand je rentre à
la maison elle me dit elle crie sur
mendy mais ton cartable dans la cuisine
et vador donc au niveau scolarité c'est
l'échec total et j'en suis attristé par
ce que pourront à l'école c'est quelque
chose de très important c'est le creuset
de la république c'est par là qu'on
construit les citoyens c'est pour ça
elle est depuis jules ferry obligatoire
pour ce qui est de l'école je peux quand
même salué une réforme prochaine ou peut
être mise en route à savoir obligatoire
dès l'âge de 3 ans pour la maternelle
pas ces enfants-là généralement ils vont
pas la maternelle reste à la maison
jusqu'à 6 ans peut-être qu'à trois ans
obligatoire il pourra apprendre
un minimum de bagages et aller à l'école
au cp avec un minimum de savoir de mots
de vocabulaire également dans la réforme
est prévue le dédoublement des classes
pour qu'on puisse tous les instituteurs
me disent quand on a une classe
nombreuses on peut pas s'occuper des
enfants issus de l'immigration
donc voilà la scolarité au niveau de
l'emploi et de la sécurité de la
formation professionnelle je dis
peut-être qu'ils vont s'accrocher à la
formation professionnelle j'ai demandé à
un jeune qui me dit qu'elle est
libérable dans quelques semaines je dis
qu'il faut pas revenir en prison il m'a
dit vous inquiétez pas je dis qu'est ce
que tu vas faire comme travail bref il
sait rien faire et je les pousse est à
ses derniers retranchements il me dit
monsieur s'est-il nous qu'est-ce qu'on
adore on assoit la drogue soit la syrie
voilà l' agence d'emploi qu'ils ont et
là j'ai compris que la syrie c'était une
motivation purement alimentaire pour
beaucoup de jeunes donc famille école
formation professionnelle au niveau de
l'emploi
même ceux qui réussissent au niveau de
l'école généralement ils sont pas
acceptés et j'en ai connu même dans ma
famille qui n'ont jamais fait la prison
et la demande d'emploi est refusé il
suffit de changer le nom mettre le nom
de quelqu'un d'autre et de l'activité
tout de suite avec un profil
psychiatrique un sur deux a déjà eu à
faire un médecin et un psychiatre ou un
psychologue et le profil pénale est le
suivant et j'invente rien âge délits
mineurs ensuite les jeunes majeurs 18 25
30 ans toute la population pénale en
france et à peu près ça les trois quarts
les déliés ce sont des délits mineurs
michel foucault dix essais 10
illégalismes irrespectueux à la légalité
se comportent en dehors de la légalité
souvent si en rapport avec leur mode de
vie dans les cités et y la durée des
peines
écoutez bien 6 7 mois et après ils
sortent dehors dans la nature donc face
à
ces gens là la prise que faut-il faire
notre système pénal sur quoi repose ti
et dans le reste du monde si il y à deux
piliers deux façons de réagir
il y à la punition et il ya la
réinsertion en france pour des raisons
peut-être historique religieuse ou autre
on préfère la punition cependant le
christianisme jésus il a porté la croix
pour le rachat de l'humanité à nous
aussi de racheter nos fautes par la
punition
il ya ceux dans les pays scandinaves
c'est le contraire ce qui compte c'est
pas la punition sont les protestants
ceux qui sont pragmatiques ceux qui
contiennent la réinsertion
une journée de prison en france elle
coûte ans dans les pays scandinaves
coûte quatre fois plus parce qu'il à
l'hébergement la nourriture yacht mais
il ya aussi la réinsertion apprendre un
métier
écrire à ses employeurs avoir des
contacts ainsi de suite
notre système pénal pour ces jeunes
à mon avis mérite d'être revu étudiez
privilégier la réinsertion
une garde des sceaux il ya quelques
années a proposé après un an de travail
avec des magistrats et des praticiens
les contraintes pénale c'est à dire que
pour ses petites et 10 la vole une
mobylette il a fait une bagarre ou autre
le condamné à travailler aller à l'école
à faire une formation professionnelle à
faire un suivi médical et ainsi de suite
sa part vu là on n'a pas vu le jour
gardez la prison pour les gros délits
les gens qui ont du sang sur les mains
ou les radicaliser où les terroristes
là je comprends mais même pour cela je
choisis le dialogue avec eux je vais les
voir régulièrement et je pensais des
fois à germaine tillon pendant la guerre
d'algérie dans les années 50
allez le voir elle les gens du fln et
elle discutait avec eux elle leur disait
c'est pas possible que votre religion
vous autorise à tuer des gens innocents
a des gens civile et elle a réussi à
convaincre plus d'un pour arrêter les
attentats
alger et à paris donc le dialogue c'est
une arme redoutable même avec les
terroristes
notre regard nous devons changer notre
regard
pour que notre société soit davantage
souder davantage unis et pour conclure
j'aime citer cette phrase de voltaire
qui dit ceci nous sommes tous égaux sur
des riffs si cher sans roi sans sujet
tous libres est tous égaux et tout
strathairn elle tous frères voilà ce qui
pourrait nous sauver c'est changer de
regard des avis des des populations
démunies ou le destine à miss
stigmatiser que ce soit dans les
banlieues dans les prisons dans les
hôpitaux les personnes âgées ou les
jeunes de façon à ce que la france
puisse s'atteler à des défis majeurs qui
sont d'ordre économique géopolitique et
autres ne rajoutons pas notre désunion
notre regard réducteur sur les uns et
sur les autres je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]